c'était vraiment au delà de nos attentes
énormément de fierté beaucoup d'espoir
magique woodstock
[Musique]
qui est vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes ça nous sommes un peu
encouragé ça m'a vraiment inspirée de
voir tout ce monde là les sabots c'est
devenu la plus importante manifestation
de l'histoire du québec
qu'on arrête de polluer la planète
près d'un demi million de personnes qui
marchent dans les rues de montréal
parmi eux il y avait aurélie et ses
parents un an plus tard il pense avoir
fait leur petite part pour aider la
planète
je suis encore plus éco consciente que
jelle l'était avant je suis je réfléchis
plus à mes achats je réfléchis beaucoup
plus à ce que je fais quotidiennement -
gaspillage macherel exemple si je suis
dans une épicerie
je suis sur le point d'acheter quelque
chose si je sais que je peux l'acheter
dans un emballage que je peut réutiliser
après je veux le faire à la place dans
nos petites actions que nous sommes
c'est sûr que on sait pas ça fait une
énorme différence mais c'est mieux que
rien lilou et albert ont organisé la
manifestation et attirer greta thoune
berg à montréal lilou a même prononcé un
discours à ses côtés mais j'entends
majeur qu'on a pu observer c'était
davantage
les mentalités dans l'opinion publique
c'est les gens qui se positionne
davantage contre les projets polluants
qui accordent davantage d'importance à
l'environnement
la situation politique est pratiquement
la même malgré quelques paysages un peu
évolué notamment dans les discours on
prend un peu plus son compte
l'environnement mais c'est surtout pour
les apparences jusqu'à maintenant
désillusion c'est le terme qu'il
choisisse sans hésiter premier
anniversaire de leur marche quand je
pense au gouvernement qui investissent
encore massivement dans les industries
polluantes plutôt que d'essayer de
réinvestir ça pour trouver d'autres
emplois durables pour la population les
employés de ces inutiles on est la cause
qu'ils servent hier d'avec wet wet haine
qui n'aurait jamais dû avoir lieu s'ils
allaient le gouvernement considérait
sérieusement la lutte climatique dans
son ensemble écologiste de longue date
et bras droit de david suzuki au québec
pendant 12 ans karel mayrand soutient
que l'ampleur des manifestations de 2019
a quand même forcé la main des élus qui
s'est passé quelque chose il ya des
décisions qui ont été prises au
gouvernement d'accélérer sa faim d'aussi
notamment le dossier de la consigne mais
évidemment l'appel qui avait été fait
c'était de répondre à la crise
climatique potes de faire du recyclage
on ressent vraiment peu qui trouve ça
important parce que sinon il ya des
changements plus flagrant qui se fait
c'est sûr ça prend des mesures comme pas
plus qu'une voiture par famille
c'est la loi pol droit de pau fins de
recyclage c'est la loi si t'en fais pas
que tu es plus taxés le gouvernement
doit commencer à vraiment
mettre en place des vraies solutions que
je souhaitais travail qui s'est mis en
place à cause que vivre l'aco vide
en quelques mois elle a fait passer
l'avenir de la planète au second plan
moi ce que je trouve le cam est affreux
démarche là c'était la copie du
gouvernement il faut mettre l'emphase
sur la relance économique en priorité
avant de penser à l'environnement
malheureusement on a été affectée par
l'aco vie de ce mouvement s'est fait
scier les jambes part parce que ce qui
nous rassemble est c'est la capacité
d'être ensemble
mais paradoxalement pour ses militants
le coronavirus offre une occasion unique
de réinventer notre économie la chance à
saisir pour la planète
la vraie victoire pour moi et à l est n
est plus possible
encore que jamais pour une raison que la
copie de faire en sorte que les
gouvernements vont injecter massivement
des fonds dans la relance économique
si cette intervention là elle vise à
répondre à la crise climatique en
relançant l'économie
on va avoir gagné 6,7 relance là elle se
fait comme avant là on va avoir perdu on
a quand même vu qu'on pouvait arrêter
l'économie qu'on pouvait ralentir et que
le monde ne s'effondrait pas que la vie
continue et ça ne prend presque une
économie de guerre qui vise la
transition énergétique puis la lutte aux
changements climatiques mais karel
mayrand le sait les mesures un peu plus
radicales ont toujours été difficile à
faire accepter en juin il a quitté la
fondation david suzuki et le
militantisme
moi j'avais l'impression de refaire les
mêmes batailles tout le temps tout le
temps au temps et c'était c'est devenu
comme très démotivant sans que ça donne
quelque chose ça que ben en fait ça a
donné des choses on gagne des petites
batailles on réussit pas à changer la
direction du titanic
il s'est donc la barre du navire à lille
où albert et aurélie à cette génération
qui a manifesté partout au québec il ya
un an
l'humanité selon lui a peut-être trente
ans de retard pour éviter les dégâts
mais les jeunes ont encore beaucoup à
sauver pour eux et pour la planète